let there be no doubt the future of
Schengen if it's taken time is running
out every week decisions are taken in
Europe which testify to how grave the
situation is reintroduction of border
controls or technical barriers at the
borders this is a clear demonstration
that we need to regain the control of
our external border in this connection I
welcome to declaration made by Slovakia
the Czech Republic and Hungary today of
committing 225 officials to rain falls
from Tex and ESO securing our borders
also requires that our rules and laws
are applied the European Union will
stick to its international obligations
in terms of asylum right but it must be
created without registration there will
be no right if a migrant does not
cooperate there must be consequences our
main point of discussion however was on
Turkey we feel confident that mutual
beneficial relationship can be
established that to help us confront the
present crisis together with President
Younker i will meet president hair done
and Prime Minister Davutoglu next Monday
end emergence of the g20 summit we are
ready to hold a special permit of the 28
member states with Turkey as soon as
possible I do not have a date yet but it
could still be this year after a new
government has been formed we need to
act fast as a union Jonas we body to
mom's not happy at all with the
relocation pace that we've seen to date
130 people have been relocated and yet
our intention was to relocate 160,000 so
we continue it that rate will be yeah
they are about 2101 nobody at today's
meeting called into question the need to
relocate these refugees nobody called
into question the flicker of 160,000
people to fear
it's a middle person